Crétin de cerveau !
Ouais ! C'est le titre d'une nouvelle série de vidéos que j'ai décidé de consacrer à ce qu'on appelle les biais cognitifs.
Les biais cognitifs, ce sont des situations
ou des circonstances
où on commet des erreurs de jugement
ou alors on prend des décisions irrationnelles
et de manière un peu systématique.
Et ça peut aller assez loin puisqu'on peut même se faire influencer et manipuler.
Pour lutter contre ces biais cognitifs
qui peuvent nous pourrir notre façon de réfléchir,
la première chose c'est déjà d'en avoir conscience.
D'où l'idée de faire une série de vidéos dessus.
Et le premier biais cognitif dont on va parler aujourd'hui, on l'appelle l'effet de halo.
L'effet de halo c'est le fait d'attribuer des qualités à quelqu'un uniquement sur la base de son apparence physique.
En fait le terme vient de ces espèces d'auréoles
qu'on peignait notamment au dessus des saints
dans les peintures médiévales.
Alors vous voulez un exemple simple de l'effet de halo ?
En bien, voici la liste de tous les présidents
des Etats-Unis depuis le début du XXème siècle.
Et voici leurs tailles respectives.
Vous ne trouvez pas qu'il y a un truc bizarre ?
Ben ouais, ils font quasiment tous plus d'1m80.
La moyenne de leur taille c'est 1m83.
C'est un peu étonnant quand on sait que la taille moyenne chez les hommes aux Etats-Unis, c'est 1m75.
La raison de ça, c'est que le grand public,
c'est à dire ceux qui votent,
semble avoir une préférence pour les grands candidats,
probablement parce que le fait d'être grand,
bah ça en impose, ça fait leader,
même si, à priori, ça n'a pas grand chose à voir
avec la capacité à gouverner un pays.
Mais malheureusement, il faut savoir que ce genre de différence on ne le retrouve pas seulement
pour les présidents des États-Unis,
mais aussi, au quotidien,
pour nous, dans le monde du travail.
Dans une étude qui a été publiée en 2004, il y a des chercheurs qui ont montré en étudiant 8500 personnes
que les grands sont, en moyenne,
ieux payés que les petits.
Et l'effet est loin d'être négligeable. Toute chose égale par ailleurs, l'impact sur le salaire annuel,
c'est 300$ par cm.
Ça veut dire que pour 20cm de différence de taille, il y a, en moyenne, 6000$ de différence de salaire à l'année.
Et ouais, quand même !
Et comme vous pouvez vous en douter, il n'y a pas que la taille qui nous induit en erreur quand il s'agit de juger des personnes,
il y a aussi évidemment l'attractivité physique.
Et pour ce genre de phénomène,
la source la plus intéressante de données,
c'est le site américain OkCupid.
OkCupid, c'est un site de rencontre en ligne, c'est un peu l'équivalent américain de Meetic, si vous voulez.
Il se trouve que l'un des fondateurs de OkCupid
qui s'appelle Christian Rudder est un féru de statistiques,
et il s'est amusé à utiliser la grande quantité de données qu'il y avait sur son site pour essayer de comprendre
comment les gens se comportaient en matière de rencontre.
Alors, à une époque sur le site quand on visualisait le profil de quelqu'un,
c'est à dire une photo et puis un descriptif,
on pouvait mettre deux notes.
Une note de physique
et une note de personnalité.
Toutes les deux sur une échelle de 1 à 5.
A priori, il s'agit de deux choses complètement différentes.
On a envie de penser que le physique va plutôt se juger sur la photo et que la personnalité va majoritairement se juger sur le texte.
Et bien, regardons les statistiques.
Sur ce graphique, chaque point représente une personne qui a mis sont profil sur OkCupid,
avec en abscisse la note moyenne de physique
qu'il ou elle a obtenu
et en ordonnée, sa note de personnalité.
Ce qu'on voit, c'est que les deux sont très bien corrélées.
C'est-à-dire que les gens qui reçoivent une note basse en physique vont aussi avoir une note basse en personnalité.
Et réciproquement, ceux qui ont une note élevée en physique reçoivent comme par miracle une note élevée en personnalité.
Amusant non ?
Alors quand on voit une corrélation comme ça, il faut toujours être prudent. J'avais parlé de quelques pièges statistiques dans mon épisode sur le paradoxe de Simpson.
Et dans ce cas précis, on pourrait imaginer que, en fait, c'est le texte qui va influencer la note que l'on va recevoir en physique.
Ça serait chouette non ?
Sauf que dans les données d'OkCupid,
on trouve des situations comme celle-ci.
Par exemple, cette jeune fille, elle fait partie des 1%
les mieux notées en terme de personnalité.
Et son profil il est complètement vide.
Il y a juste sa photo, pas de texte.
Ah ouais, sacrée personnalité !
Alors comme chez OkCupid ce sont des gens qui sont sérieux du point de vue des statistiques, ils ont décidé de faire une vraie expérience bien contrôlée
pour voir quel était le lien entre la note de physique
et la note de personnalité.
Pour un certain nombre de profils, ils se sont amusés
à l'afficher aléatoirement avec ou sans le texte.
C'est-à-dire que la moitié des visiteurs qui venaient voir l'un de ces profils, le voyait normalement,
tandis que l'autre moitié ne voyait que la photo,
le texte était effacé.
Et ils se sont amusés à comparer les notes attribuées
à chacun de ces profils dans les deux cas; suivant qu'il y avait juste la photo ou bien photo et texte.
Alors sur ce graphique chaque point représente
un de ces profils avec en abscisse la note obtenue quand il y avait uniquement la photo
et en ordonnée, la note obtenue quand il y avait la photo et le texte.
Et encore une fois, on voit une très belle corrélation.
Ce résultat il veut dire qu'on va vous attribuer à peu près la même note de personnalité que vous mettiez du texte ou que vous en mettiez pas.
Autant dire que la photo joue beaucoup, c'est à dire que c'est un bel effet de halo.
Alors si vous aimez ce genre de stats, je vous recommande d'aller voir le blog de OkCupid qui compile tout un tas de données de ce genre
et notamment des corrélations entre les notes que vous allez recevoir ou le nombre de messages
et la manière dont est prise votre photo.
C'est vraiment, très très intéressant.
Alors si OkCupid, ça ne vous parait pas trop trop sérieux comme source. Rassurez-vous ! Il existe plein de publications scientifiques qui ont étudié de manière systématique
ces effets de halo liés à l'apparence physique, et on va en voir quelques-uns.
L'étude fondatrice sur les effets de halo, elle date des années 70 et vous allez voir que ses conclusions vont à peu près dans le même sens que ce qu'on vient de voir.
Il s'agit d'une expérience dans laquelle on a montré des photos à un groupe de sujets
et on leur a demandé de juger de la personnalité
des personnes représentées sur la photo.
En ayant juste la photo, les sujets devaient noter
les personnes sur un certain nombre de critères
comme leur sincérité, leur modestie, leur gentillesse,
leur altruisme, leur sérieux, leur sensibilité...
ce genre de choses.
Il y avait 27 critères comme ça.
Et on a comparé les notes obtenues en fonction de l'attractivité physique de la personne
qui était représentée sur la photo.
Et là, ben, sans surprise, on a trouvé
que la note de personnalité des personnes jugées physiquement attirantes,
était bien meilleure que celle des personnes
qui étaient jugées moyennes ou bien peu attirantes.
Et au-delà de ces jugements de personnalité, le biais cognitif lié à l'effet de halo, il peut avoir des conséquences assez graves.
Il y a un chercheur de l'université de Toronto qui a voulu étudier dans quelle mesure le physique des gens
nous influençait quand on était juge dans un procès.
Donc il a fait un expérience dans laquelle il s'agissait
de décider si quelqu'un était coupable
sur la base d'un texte qui décrivait les faits
accompagné de la photo de la personne jugée.
Evidemment, l'idée était de regarder ce qu'il se passe quand on garde le texte à l'identique mais qu'on change l'attractivité de la personne représentée sur la photo.
Et les gens qu'on soumettait à l'expérience, ils devaient juger de la culpabilité de la personne en la notant sur une échelle de 0 à 5.
0 c'était clairement pas coupable
et 5 c'était clairement coupable.
Et voici la moyenne des notes obtenues.
On voit une sacrée différence de culpabilité présumée en fonction du physique de la personne sur la photo.
Et aussi pour la sévérité de la peine attribuée, on observe la même chose.
Un physique attirant, et le juge sera plus clément .
Ah oui, petit détail technique. L'effet était beaucoup plus prononcé quand un homme devait juger de la culpabilité d'une femme, que l'inverse.
Ben, ouais...
Et voilà, c'était pour l'effet de halo.
Alors des biais cognitifs comme celui-ci,
il en existe tout un tas et on les verra dans les épisodes suivants de la série "Crétin de cerveau !"
J'espère que vous trouverez ça utile de les connaître
et puis aussi, ça vous montrera que ces biais,
ils ont été étudiés scientifiquement par des chercheurs en psychologie et en sociologie.
Et ça sera une très bonne occasion pour moi
de vous montrer que ces disciplines
comme la psychologie ou la sociologie,
qu'on a un peu tendance à associer
à de la lecture de magazines de comptoir,
en fait ce sont des vrais sciences.
Il y a des chercheurs qui font des expériences bien contrôlées, qui adoptent une démarche scientifique
et qui font des publications scientifiques à la fin,
dont je ne manquerai pas de vous mettre les sources.
Et voilà, et donc prochain épisode très bientôt. Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo, comme d'habitude pour ne rien rater vous pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne.
N'hésitez pas à partager la vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux pour m'aider à faire connaitre la chaîne. Vous pouvez suivre d'ailleurs l'actu de la chaîne sur Facebook ou sur Tweeter.
Ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent me soutenir sur Tipeee. Une fois de plus, merci beaucoup à tous les tipers.
Et vous pouvez jeter un œil à mon livre
que j'ai sorti chez Flammarion.
Merci, à bientôt !